my name is alice kaplan i am
director of the french department
here at yale and it is a great pleasure
to introduce you to the writer kamel daoud
kamel daoud entered
literary history through an engagement with albert
camus complex and inventive he
taught us to look again and to
question many
received ideas he told me during an interview
that each country has its piece
today he will talk about meursault in the
company of robinson another
founding figure of the  modern imaginary
hello I apologize for not taking the
podium it reminds me too much of the
single party and it reminds me too much of
dictatorships so it makes me uncomfortable
I prefer to be standing and
talking to you normally
I have been invited  to talk about a theme
called that I had even
suggested the stranger as being an
unhappy robinsonnade
the robinson mytho it's a myth that has
fascinated me since childhood I
discovered it very early on I think of  the age of
10 years I read this magnificent novel by
pagnol defect on robinson crusoe that
you all know over the years
I had understood that robinson was the
case was the illustration of a
fundamental myth of humanity
it is the myth  of the encounter with
the other and in my eyes many great
stories many great myths are
declined as robinsonnade robinson was
not born with daniel default he was
born long before with among others an
Andalusian philosopher called des
motos file  who was Arab who had
written rewrote above all a
magnificent fable called naïve new york
gives translate into French the living
son of the vigilant and it was one of the
first formulas of the robinsonade m
a lack in a desert island and see
how it s  comes out how he can
discover god or else rebuild civilization
and blue tofail with aviesan another
muslim philosopher of the time and
mystic was fascinated by the
vertical relationship they founded what the
philosophers of the Middle Ages who were called
the self-taught philosopher, that is to say
a man lost on an island and how
he will rebuild the faith and the
philosophical system of his religion
that is why he is called the living
son of the vigilant  it's someone who
reconstructs a philosophy therefore written
by avicenna taken up in the
heritage of hindu mythology re
written by bono tofail and then rewritten
again by robin without that by daniel de
faux the mic is not dead i think that
at every moment civilizations
wondering about the role and end up
rewriting the robinsonade a century
later another writer
also rewrote the robinsonade I think you
know him it was michel tournier who
wrote a magnificent novel
called  friday or the limbo of the
pacific
so it's a myth that fascinates me for
two or three reasons the first is
that it raises the question of the
human condition facing the other what
should i do when i  e meeting the other
is in my eyes this confrontation where
this meeting comes in
several forms
I had noticed that when we meet
the other we can kill him and bury him it's
called abel and his brother we can
meet the other  other and try to
convert him
it's called robinson crusoe and also you
can meet the other and kill him it's
called camus's stranger and i was
fascinated by this perspective of the
robinsonnade in camus's stranger
in my opinion, we find there
very strong signals of a rewriting of an
ancient myth of humanity
first of all north au you like arable it's
like friday
if we say arabic we don't have his first name
so we don't  don't know if he's alive we
don't know if he has a soul this one does
n't have a soul if you remember robinson
hesitated in front of the other they didn't know
if they had a soul or  if he had
the soul of an animal so he called
friday
i.e. it's a weekday
meursault calls the other arab it's  it's pretty
much the same thing it's a
weekday it's a race it's an ethnic group
it's a culture it's the other it
struck me the second point the
meeting takes place on a beach  like
in the space of lille the
island space robinson walks around with a
weapon and he meets someone who does not
know he kills him friday more
province have taken on water and to do the
same thing he does not have it  killed he killed his
difference he forced him to convert
to civilization and to
religious beliefs and that also struck me 7
this similarity between between the two
so in the classic robinsonnade
that there is therefore the space it'  is lille where the
beach and there is the discovery of
the island this is
one of the important chapters in
the robinsonade were shipwrecked
we find ourselves in an unknown island and
we begin to discover their jumps does
the same  thing
he goes down he looks across the ball
when he sees people passing he
walks he is going to bury s  his mother and he
walks in the brush March in the
heat etc was also struck by this
similarity one discovers the island and in
names quite appropriate to its geography the other
also discovers lille mountain where he
lives
the hajj is to say there  where his mother was
buried I'm talking about marceau and after
it's the city it's quite
striking as similarities
third point the hermitage that is to say
the position of solitude
robinson is alone on an elected but
also receives  he is alone on an island he
is in a fallback position
he is withdrawn from
social life and the attempt to meet
people does not meet him 4 6 1 points
which struck me at the time it  is the
fauna and flora of robinson island
begins by taking lille and trying to
discover what are these animals
what are these plants these trees
he gives names to many
things but he takes away  le mans then
the black is called the black the arab
is called the arab friday his sentence
friday
on the other hand there are a lot of details
on the insects on the space on the
species of plants etc
it is quite striking this  desire to
list the world in a way
the man
is quite fascinating we give names
to everyone and we take away the mans to the man
it's for better faces and to better
deny it so I was also struck by
this fauna in the robinsonnade there
are three actors we often speak of
roman that because he is the hero he is
the one who tracks down transforms the
shipwreck into a novel while the shipwreck
on Friday is a news item
because one at the  civilization the other
there is supposed to be no
civilization there is a third
character so he at robinson
there is friday we always talk about it
forgetting the third which for me is
fascinating is the parrot the one who
says a sentence for robinson where  are
you who in my eyes is a
f character  soaring I always asked myself the
question is it possible to
tell a life with five worlds to
try to experience the limits of
long grace compared to the desire to
tell
I wrote a story that I did not
published which is called the parrot
molière ie someone who is
faced with the limits and of his
vocabulary to try to tell the
world for robinson it is the parrot
which speaks which uses five words and i
was struck  by the similarity with the
countries the animals and the people who
live in the meursault building you
remember lamps which has a dog
again which always repeats the same thing
which is totally isolated in an
enclosed space which is in a protists space
it is  the revin-year-old parrot who
now is an old man with a
dog it's quite striking this this
similarity it takes three actors the
rank parrot for me symbolizes the
limits and the disaster and
the impossibility of meeting m
it's a reflection of robinson he
's locked up in five months he's going to
tell the world etc
my children he's like the parrot
that they tell the world in five words
it's a limit of language language
poses all at once the  possibility of
telling but also given culture is
a is a protocol of recognition and
encounters but it is also a
system of denials culture makes it possible to
meet the other but above all makes it possible
to deny it
I was fascinated by this character of the
parrot someone who simply says
in the novel that we forget that
everyone forgets besides maybe that one
day I will write robinson seen by the
parrot then and then we have the
last two topics which are easily
also  it's by meeting because
there are no robinsonnades his meeting
looks are with laughter would perhaps have
died of boredom on his island if he had not
met the other and meursault
would have been a little black foot  who would have
left algeria it is not had  t not killed
the grater the other is both
necessary for life but also for
the story therefore the meeting is
important
abel killed his brother because he
met him piece which europe because he
met  robin are sure
friday by converting him because he
met him
the meeting is essential and that's
what makes the myth of the robinsonade
different
it starts with a shipwreck a
recognition and then with a meeting
and beyond  of the meeting
everyone finds finding a way out michel
tournier brought a variant the
meeting in the friday where the
limbo of the pacific
robinson takes his gun
he will try to kill friday because he
says to himself if i let him live his
compatriots will try to
chasing him they will discover me they
will kill me the problem is that
when shooting he slips he misses
he kills the one the pursuers don't kill
Friday the encounter is immoral she
and the ethical parks
it's based on a deep misunderstanding
he first he wanted to kill him he didn't
want to save him that's the whole
fundamental difference between friday
or the limbo of the pacific of
tournier and robinson crusoe the
dating words are different in  mersault
counter-investigation I kill him he will be three
hours the last topic
is what we do with the other
abel bury his brother or the opposite
friday converted so he is killed and
in mersault he is completely erased
that  is always resolved with a false
survival the one who survives the
robinsonade does not survive because he is
going to kill the other he had the possibility
of meeting to live his humanity
the robinsons ap always end badly
unfortunately that is to say we don't  ca
n't manage to share lead we can't live
together we can't change
the angle of vision is it
possible that on a Friday
and then write in his tradition in his
robinson language that they would have  for example
like  nt check it how can he
conceive it
it's michel tournier's fantasy he
said that no robinson was
basically impossible because
until now we haven't written the
robinsonnade seen by friday in all
this to tell you that  I was fascinated
by this myth and it was for me a
way when I wrote this novel a
way of taking up the Robinsonade and
telling it
from the other point of view that said when
I reflect I am not  intelligent
so if I tell you all this
now
don't believe that I had a
very precise construction in my head
while writing I wrote a novel and it was
later that I discovered that it is
articulated is  more or less on a
protocol or or a lack so it's an
easy novel you can read it with
pleasure
then this novel is not an answer
abroad because
I wanted from the beginning to evacuate this
misunderstanding I don't  am not a truck i
am not someone who runs around
alb  ert camus
i think that there are too many
trucks and they do their job much
better than me on the other hand
i have here but only because
i am algerian only because i was
born long after the war of
independence in algeria than  because
I have a mad love for the
French language as well and for literature
in general, it gives me a
sort of playful legitimacy,
that is to say this possibility of
taking up a masterpiece and
writing to them at my  way
when the novel was published in algeria in
november 2013
there was a misunderstanding from the start
some because they know that i am a
very virulent journalist in
answered me le mans see messages
saying it's perfect and congratulations
you  you round a slap albert camus
then it was not the case
it was a novel which tried to leave
the Franco Algerian circle not in
the denial of the story but to try
to get out of the story precisely so
the novel is  gone on a m  ode heard
agen in 2014 it was bought by acts
sud est
it was published we are we are
generally for those who know
a little bit about the book industry in
france and a season finally this one
is not the good
the good period  to release a book,
that's where you have a
survival time of about a month because
afterwards it's the holidays and then on
the start of the literary season and you're dead
so I said to myself it doesn't matter  nothing
so we are going to publish it and to mark the
occasion but I did not think that the
novel was going to have such an immense echo
in France and from the start I was afraid
of the French reception as much as
I was afraid of the Algerian reception
why because we are two countries
marked by history and the weight of
history by colonial crime and
afterwards and so I thought badly
I have nothing written in French on
albert camus that's all  prepared for
a media controversy over
repentance the memory has it  lgeria
france etc
it was not the case from the first
articles in the world or in other
newspapers
I was pleasantly surprised people
did not give him a test of the tours
did not read that  an answer albert camus
they read a novel of writing and I
think that the most beautiful tribute that one
can pay hours a book is to
read with pleasure and so it was more
or less a pleasant surprise for me
but  there were a lot of anecdotes
also for those who have not read the
novel explains so meursault you
remembered some and years later the brother
of the grater meets someone in a
bar and he explains to him the brother mans
c  is his so at the beginning the narrator
who is called by the yardstick of his parents more
or less in my novel is very
angry with albert camus against
mersault so he is someone he is
and violent who  attack who responds
to their aggression the second part of the
novel is a criticism is a
very harsh vision on the  algeria now and
not only algeria on the
conditions in the so-called arab world or
religious association and some readers
told me for example in algeria that the
first part was magnificent but the
second was average is a game where i
made a  meeting a ten-
year-old tv show with the french philosopher mickaël
crap that there was a black foot
he told me exactly the opposite he
told me the first part is average
but the second is magnificent
and that's all for me  the whole cough
the confinement in the
Algerian-French space to the Franco-Algerian of
countries which do not arrive at ircam and
like a snub-nosed writer and seen discussing
like a philosopher like a man who
is part of an era but  that one
cannot read like a man
capable of writing novels because
when there are too many stories there is a
weakening there is a pole of wandering
vis-à-vis fiction
totalitarian regimes do not like  the fictions he
does not believe in  totalitarian regimes
fiction is a message to divert
the imagination does not have the dignity of a
vision and in countries that are marked
by an excellent history how to manage
france camus the novel by camus are
read as artifices n  can't
believe camus's novel
we try to interpret it decode it force
the reading we analyze camus we
face asthma not with year we do
n't stay with year we try to
understand and it's quite striking
the imagination is  what is impossible
in countries that are marked by
history or marked by totalitarian regimes
is fiction
rarely tolerated totalitarianisms produce
novels first of all that are pedagogical
soviet realism or that are too
intended for  Illustrate a policy that
whoever comes closer to propaganda results
in novels that no one reads that
literature disappears needs
that the imaginary be respected
as something fundamental  mental is
not like an artifice so all that to
tell you that the reception France in
Algeria has been good and very good moreover
and at the same time it has caused a lot
of a
lot of reading a lot of
controversy and a lot of a lot
of  interpretations and over-
interpretations
this was not the case in other countries
the novel and was translated the moment
finally a long time ago and I
was waiting for the other languages ​​because I said to myself the whole challenge
is to  to be able to write a novel not a
nationality is to be able to talk about
the human condition
so when i saw that the novel was
well received in vietnam in poland or
elsewhere gt gt surprised and at the same time
i was curious to see how we
surely read because it's a novel that I
wanted independent of my nationality
independent of what I am therefore and I
think that the translation site is for
me the best reward because
if I arrived before a novel in  28
languages
is that  e maybe i touched
something human and something
deep now for the american edition
i was first that as it's
really be translated here it's you and
then  I was surprised by the number
of articles that were published but
really surprised we exceeded the don't know
state of about 200 articles
which is extraordinary
it means that vein that creates more
on the novel than  the volume of novel
itself since which is not bad so I
may have explained things to myself
finally I tried to understand because
in England also their word works very
very well and I said to myself maybe
it  is due to a colonial tradition
in the universities it is
also perhaps due to the fact that camus is
someone who treats himself george bush
used the foreigner of camus it is
also perhaps due to  fact that there is an
inversion of perspectives and their
contribution the entry fundamentally
fundamentally can be  being troubled at home does
not allow you to judge i am not
american what relationship do you have with
the other that they are different pro
from a different culture america it is
in my eyes someone who sees from afar
it  is both the miracle of having
founded his nation on the relationship to
the other and the contribution of the other and at the
same time on the denial of the other it's
quite striking that's what  does all the
traffic in the word diversity, which encompasses
enrichment and difference at the same time,
so maybe I can explain that too, maybe
also that we're in fashion
now because it was perhaps
the writers who came from  cold in
the days of the 70s now it's
the writers who come from the desert
so maybe people
are interested in how and the other
what does he think what does he
do  because it has also become a
question of security
maybe the one who didn't tell me that I
want to understand him too why does
he want to kill me that's enough  z strange
the news because 72 years ago
camus wrote the story of a black foot
who passes who killed laraque who does not know
72 years after you have someone who
walks on a beach and who shoots who
kills in tunisia dozens of two years old
who absolutely do not know the same
place the same sun the same absurdity
it's quite fascinating also game I try
to find leads of interest but hey
sometimes it's like for the stories
of  love you have to live them you must not
explain them thank you for this
conference aids thank you especially for a
re mans which what
I find absolutely fascinating
but about diversity and I
had not thought of this comparison
obviously the comparison between between
the foreigner of camus obviously be different
and but the comparison with
art vincent it's fascinating there is
another series of texts or intertek
stcum let's say literary criticism it's
the storm of shakespeare
and then a whole series of post texts
colonials which reinvents itself in a
way and I was wondering and there you have
the other one who speaks one even at
Shakespeare you have only in Lebanon who
speaks
I like and Cesaire you have a storm
and you have a calibrant which has us
qu  they who have a lot of things and I
wonder if you had thought of this
comparison or if you're interested I'm
interested I didn't think
I don't think once again that we
write a very good novel if we  thinks
too much writes beautiful you have beautiful
essays but not good novels because
the act of fiction is different it is an
art which exists both
absolute rigor but at the same time a
kind of freedom that is needed  cultivating
is it's quite paradoxical it takes
years to learn to write novels
but when you start to write them you
absolutely have to forget all that that's what they will
see the intertextuality in
living novels is  because it
is not artificial all
impartiality had artificial  is seen is
felt the reader feels them he
rejects
unless the writer is intelligent enough
to do something
both for structured products
intersexuality not but in the
playful by the playful also by what
is aggressive insolent  also so there are there are
both I'm a great reader
maybe I write novels
because out of frustration these are
novels that I would have liked to read that did
n't exist when I was  as a child we
didn't have a book so I was reading a
novel I reread it and I reread it I'm
happy and because
langoat was hungry as soon as it finished
what should I do and nothing so
I reread the novel and then for a while I
learned a fantasy and to write
stories from the titles of other
novelists know at the end of the appeared
it's the lord of the rings so I
took the title since the book
did not exist  not I imagined it I
sometimes built I said I say
in lectures  es and what is
also very true that sometimes it's better when
I read the lord of the rings after
my story was better but hey
the title is magnificent the lord of the
rings why when he lives in a
village that does not have  of books has
opened up
so I also have a relationship with the texts
that exist and intertek what does not exist
also as giscours evocation
confrontation the book is a fantasy
I am marked by this culture where the
book is a fantasy so I  I also have a
relationship to intertextuality and to the
game of text that someone illustrated very well,
it's fine linen, that is to say
where the text participates does not
only participate in an intellectual game, it
participates in the will of  to appropriate to
devour of to be in a relationship of
predation and appropriation of the
other's text I do with it what I want
it is at the base of all culture there is
a mark of predation I think  that at the
base of all writing there is an act of
predation one cannot  can't write
novels with respect he takes the
writings with insolence
it's something fundamental
i heard you talk come on so what
i feel is in the novel
first of all you name the  brother
give you a name that she didn't
give him
you write in French you should have
written in Arabic I
took the lan I remember a
conference in Haiti where I regularly there is a
concert here we say we  a we
kept we made the French language
our language you are sure of subversion
you did not do what you write
in French give an Arabic name and I
think that this subversion for the
French and for the Algerians because
somewhere where  you also encouraged the
Algerians appropriates validating to be
part continue to appropriate the
French language double section on
version and when you say that it is
a form of insolence but especially
if you have a style and respect
because you  give a name and therefore
you are doing the opposite of what you
write about what the roba was doing
are not named and it is therefore
somewhere you get out of the
colonial situation by giving equality and
respect finally here I do not know I
feel things
thanks to them
when we are in a story that
should be called postcolonial we are we are we
are in this kind of text to say we
are marked by the texts others
why because the other the one who
did violence to you  and you have
contact with him by two means
okay because he has arms because
he has books okay so at the
same time
he represents a
fundamental contradiction he represents an ideal but
also a crime so you come  in
countries where this contradiction is described
differently either not a rejection of
the other by the choice to deliver on
the other so it depends one day
resists brilon français asked me the
question he told me how  you get
a counter result  adiction between the
French of culture and the French
colonizer and its simply answered
cdc your in contradiction it's up to you
to solve it it's not me me I
take what interests me so why
I tell you that it's  to tell you do
n't think i wrote a truly
revolutionary i wrote a novel
now did i escape the
revolution post colonial culture
the history of colonization etc
yes but many people  and in particular
in the United States in sight and it is normal the
novel through this syndrome of
colonized posts whereas the stake of this
novel religion is god because
for those who read camus and the stranger
of albert  camus
we recapitulate piece does not react
when he kisses a woman in the
die or the place the weather is very beautiful it is
a success the basin subsidiary of happiness
but he does not react he does not react
stupid he says it besides at work  do
n't react the judge bully him don't react
hard  before his trial he did not react
he reacted only once the
last five pages thanks to god to his priest
these are the most beautiful pages of
songs it is when he is confronted with
the question of the god that marceau
wakes up that's it  it's is for me the
camus wrote two religious novels and
I dare the word it's the fall
obviously the novel that I really like the
most to those who paid homage
by ascending and it's the foreigner
deeply religious novels which which in
my opinion deals with the
fundamental question of the 20th century and especially of the
21st century now it's the question
of the god it's not the question of the colosseum
where I committed is at the limit
yes we n  escape its history but
we try to talk about it to make a
book of it so but at the same time the
essential question is not the
question of the position of the colonized it is the
question of freedom in the face of a god or
those who speak for us it's hard
especially
so maybe there was a
misunderstanding  u I don't write under duress
no I live within systems of
constraints but on the contrary
writing is precisely for me the
only recreational moment in relation to the
constraints of belief
political propaganda violence aggression or
contrary history  writing is what
allows me to free myself
it's the only space of freedom
that I'm afraid that they will exercise them so
I write a
lot I write a lot from a graphic point of view
of the effects  a lot of
newspaper articles written but people
ask me the question at the time it's
how come for the three articles
a day for example or four months it
was not a problem it's so many
things to say that at the  the opposite is it's
jeans goiset deeply when
I know that I'm nearing the end of a
good novel or the end of a text it's
the opposite life to an order when I
write it  it's when I don't write anymore that
she resumes her disorder
so no I don't write under the
constraint and I do not write with a
priori I said earlier that the
basic rule for me is not to
think when I write it is to be
rigorous without intellectualizing the act
of writing
because if we start to think about the
metaphor at hmr the metaphor becomes
an idea and elmer the metaphor must be
apart must be respected for what it
can and it must pay for what it
is so that  what it entails
as song writing is born from a
melody
I like the causes written I don't have
postponed dreams and melodies and
texts that come in melody
it's not anticipated texts I
don't  don't like to anticipate because that
means I'm going to work I
hate work I write while saying while
inventing while reading I think that a good
writer is the one who reads at the same
time as he writes he reads his text he him he
read the book that doesn't exist
yet as long as i'm writing from this
perspective i'm having fun i know it's
decent  vant for theoreticians but I am
having fun
so there are no rules now
that they are there are reflexes pardon
the reflexes and first the text a
melody I think that everything is born from a
sentence that we  dig in a spiral
the fact of having written I remember
very well today mansat say my
mother is still alive
the cool novel below
it's very simple listen to this even
this melody dig this metaphor is
articulated gnaw the cries very very
quickly  because it was his will and
story so there are no rules
but there are requirements there are
reflexes first reflex is that any
writer will tell you a novelist who
it's a melody it's a  music I do
n't know how to explain but you
feel when you break the rhythm and you
resume you erase the sentence and
you continue and the second I have a
deep almost physical allergy
for the cliché the cliché is my war
as soon as I see  a cliche I have to
deny it tel  it's called the style but
for me it's a hergies trunk i ca
n't stand to slip how can i
tell you for example autumn dead leaves
ok it's very simple hector a
text that i wrote recently for
myself  it was obvious it comes by itself
reverse
I wrote autumn in the number of
leaves is the oldest book in the
world because if we count the number
of leaves it is NATO which is the
oldest book in the world  and it's
obvious I mean you have to dismantle the
metaphor the style is running out you you
really have to be an academic who has
a lot of patience and willpower to
reread texts from the 19th or 17th
century the metaphor is running out
must renew it
either by a rewrite or not a
salacious proofreading capacity of 40 years old
is happy that we are starting to reread the
boring books of 20 years old and that we
discover something sublime in them this
gimmick we missed at age  of 20 years
that we recalled and therefore there is  no
rules there are requirements
there are reflexes and there are choices
in relation to the French language
I was young I was a journalist I
still am
because in Algeria it was the only
way to earn one's  life not by
writing books and I started to
write the chronicle the punctures
did one a day it was exhausting
to describe
his chronicle every day I did like my
colleagues 3 4 hours we erase in one
sentence
after I said to myself  it can't
last it's horrible I have to
understand why I can't
write normally and I understood two
things the first you can't do
two things at the same time you can't
think and write so I  I wrote the
text before and I told them ready
after I do two so to save
time also because when we do a
report we are on the way and I
totally write the hotel I get to the
editorial office
I write it  but I'm not with
words is that I don't master it  e game
I have my idea I have them the second and
it's true it's that I said to myself the
French take over who was about to
year I can do with their bank what
I want so I started  to put
clac and with this language
they are not there one belongs to
nobody it's me I write what I
want and I have since that moment I
started to write accounts easily
deconstruct mark to write to  really live it
and make it a
recreational recreational space you can't
inspire pleasure in others if
you don't experience it yourself even if you're bored to
write don't ask a voter to have
fun saying he's going he's going  to feel any
reader is intelligent even if the
idiots because he feels from the beginning
when a well-written novel when they did
n't continue the one who links the novel
is someone intelligent who must be
respected okay
we can't  lie is
like love affairs could
n't be with someone who denies you
all  a life otherwise it's
horrible so from the beginning you have to
be in a relationship of good faith in
reading it shows good faith and
always more convincing than the time
it's someone something that is
transmitted c  is something that if they
him the other basically i hope
i answered is that secularism
would be enough one day in the struggle in
the restriction that god a little basically to
freedom
how is that  we can do within the
framework of algeria also
within the framework of france you
said that the fiction offer you a space
of freedom compared to that
inside a dictatorship
religious political dictatorship any form of
dictatorship and in  at the same time this space of
fiction is constantly devoured
by history by the weight of
history and also by religion
what are we going to do where are we
going like this whether it be in algeria in
trance or in Arab Muslim countries
today is a question that I  ask me
we are different levels so
god does not impose by imposing his
different name because for the moment what
they met never
came back
so it's different
now yes I don't understand what
I often have this kind  question that
writes more anxiety than the
need for an answer and I understand it
because freedoms are shrinking
and it's difficult I always have in
a conference room in Algeria or
Tunisia are in French always
someone  someone who raises his hand to tell me
to continue you write etc
but what's the point of Molière yes it
can it can be useless but
I do it because because it gives
meaning to my life that's very  simple
it's obvious because I don't like
to be defeated tasted defeat at the beginning I
prefer to continue until the end and
because those who in this sense to a man's life
is what exceeds the duration of
his life is like that maybe
it's illusory everyone  limit but I
prefer to leave something to my
grandchildren
perhaps the memory of someone who
tried to resist rather than sinking
into oblivion saying that it is
someone who did not resist
people  now remember in the
west remembers spinoza
remembers others doesn't remember
people who gave up he
remembers people who continued
it's obvious and at the same time
why it's up to me to know
parties why by the other it's i know
i'm right
i know i didn't kill anyone i know i'm trying
to share stopped meeting
others so i'm within my rights
so it's not  it's not up to me to lower my
eyes it's not up to me to say that
I stop writing because the others
you where the others impose on us or the
others want to impose their will on us
no and then I have a slogan in  my life
like each of you who cannot
die in my place do not have the right
to live in my place  ace it's very simple
so me i keep writing i
keep traveling meeting and then
when i die i'll die
in a way maybe satisfy it
worthy these are big words but sometimes
you need to keep going and  then
I don't like love frankly I
know it's difficult I know I
said one day that the difference is that
the angles of a single book
always take a little rows they are
not free  but the waves of several
books are always tolerant and free
and I once said that I kill them
in the name of one book and I try to
speak in the name of the other books that
remain it's that simple and then  I have the
feeling of my dignity
I prefer not to lower four others
in bets whether they are secular or religious
no it's not for me it's not
courage it's just that I don't feel
I feel  not able to give
up to know it
always ends up sinking evil always
so I don't know how  Well it's going to last
I don't know if we'll see it I don't
think on the scale of a lifetime I don't have
much hope but I work
for my children my great
-grandchildren etc
g everyone has their own  vision of eternity me
I prefer the qualities that I can
share with others and what is
happening in the Arab world or in the
world itself but myers and rises in
violence etc
yes yes I agree but we are not going
don't give up
you can do it it's your choice
I can respect but me no
yes it's a good question
houellebecq's novel he is the chosen one it
is admirably well written and I
liked it a lot until the  moment when i
felt that the bad guy was me
so no that's for fun but
maybe we don't share the same way
of seeing the world
submission is also a rewrite of
the foreigner of camus
for those who have read the
totally foreign character, the young woman
by the way with the same first name is we
are we love  except that in submission
it is France that dies so it is
different and I am afraid of
totalitarianisms
we fear them but not in the same
way and the denunciations sometimes will
be made for different purposes
I prefer to denounce for the purpose of
benevolence  rather than it serving a
discourse of exclusion of the other it's
different now what the
vision that wahlberg describes in his
novel is i find it fascinating really
easily wahlberg's discourse on
his book i don't like  these differences
is what I just said
earlier, that is to say to read like a
robinsonnade for example tried to
give and counter counter investigation on the
fall rather than on the foreigner
because the foreigner c  it's a false lead
the sequel is the real lead in this
novel i think that the prospect of
robinson a speech my daughter you
fascinate me the most it's
it's both a myth but a
news now it'  is a
political question but  estion of history and
of ethics and morals what to do with
the other is the big question
now is to welcome him
throw him drown him bury him kill him
but convert him  Marrying is therefore
the question of otherness the other and
for me fascinating the other is at the
same time my freedom because it is with him
that I can make the world infinite but
it is also my limit  6 ie kill him before he
says it in his monologue he says that
the other is my limit when I kill him
these become horribly free
unnecessarily free because when one kills
a year the parts of the lily and it is sure
that I  I would like this to be
the subject of reflection it is the relationship
to the other this is what must be
redefined now thinking analyzed
assumes and we must base an ethic on
the need to live to survive
the  other it is the most urgent finally for
me if I had to teach this nickname and what
is strange what at the same time if
not when not  ask me to change
a few sentences in the novel
the initial title was the foreigner
that is to say the novel in the novel
speak of the foreigner I was asked
not to allude to the  foreign because it
belongs to a family it's a
good i chose another title reminds
the other it was an accident
but i continue best embodies what
i mean
no i don't think written for a
readership  reduces good all readership and
reduces if we are passing anyway
the myth of the writer who contains the
word does not exist we are read by 1000 2000
4000 5000 10000 and still we are bought
by his contents and elected by dimitri
not therefore it is not it is not a
deep criterion now the
French language in the Maghreb region
for example is a living language
politically denying the rope for
reasons that are easily explained in
relation to colonial crime  etc but
people speak French
French newspapers often very
very b  well we have print runs for 1
2 they have the five main
algerian newspapers ugema three which are french
which have drawn one million two hundred
thousand copies a year which is
huge for the roof will make it clear
french is doing well it's france
which doesn't lend itself well but
so it's so know it's not a
problem
the second thing is that if I
wrote the novel in French but the
language misstep criticality too much the language
afterwards I'm here you're  here the
American time therefore the novel was translated
moreover it was very well translated
American and the language becomes after the
secondary limit a good writer he is
the one who knows how to make people forget the language
and slams a crime
you have to forget it  it's that's how it is
and so no i'm just telling myself he thinks
i'm not addressing myself a minor deviation
reduces you last week i was
in beirut where the arabic translation came out
which will affect others
geographies of other other readers
so no  n I don't think that shouting
tongues doesn't unscrew the world
sharing in writing when you write
something that pleases others the chosen one
was going to translate them comment on them weary
we see she is on her journey
so no I don't consider myself to be  in a
ghetto and mystical
absolutely not and then I have a chance
I am bilingual I can switch from
Arabic to French which no problem
I do not write will do it in Arabic
because I got used to it for
reasons  professionals etc and I
normally read the rebuffs of the world
the problem is not the language when you
want to understand you want to understand
it's once again the metaphor of
love when you meet a
passer-by you really like the
language  is not important
to do only fiction
my editors absolutely want but
it is a it is a resistance why
I estimate that in the region that I live
in a factory in Morocco in France val the
chronicle that I do very light I myself
embarrassed sense of ar  to stop describing the
chronicle is a little embarrassing it's
as if I'm letting people down that's
on the one hand the second thing
is that you have to understand that we
live in structures that are
different from  yours, that is to say
we are in structures where the
journalist and the writer can be
the same
it's like the america of the 20s where
hemingway could be a journalist and a
writer and one feeds the other the
journalists feed  the writer and
but when the economy diversifies
and so it is so we become more or less
journalists or more or less write
for me now
journalism feeds the spirit of
the writer but it eats me up
so it takes me too much  of time therefore the
time that I devote to journalists
I do not devote writing novels which
my editors do not like but if I
only write novels dino buzzati
an Italian writer who was also a
journalist said that there is
something  magic to write an article to
read it the next day even if it disappears
the day after
but it's something magical
it's a drug also it's the novel
it's a rolling and the article it's a
big  suddenly
I can give an
increasingly erratic metaphor the article is a
penalty and the novel is a match but
yes we don't have the same football
I hope I haven't been at my best and
Thanks a lot